JEFF: Wow. Okay. Yeah.
It's a lot tougher to see.
Just trying to keep the,
the feet straight.
This is a lot right now.
I'm trying to keep my footing,
trying to let the rope
out at the right speed.
And I'm trying to not think
about falling to the bottom.
Like I don't know
if I can do this.
DILLON: All right, Jeff.
I'm gonna come
down and meet you.
JEFF: Okay!
Oh my gosh. Ooh.
(grunts)
DILLON: All right.
Careful feet. Careful feet.
One at a time.
JEFF: Ohh. Ohh.
(rustling)
Oh.
DILLON: Just hold it tight.
JEFF: Right now, I'm thinking
about all of these ropes and
pulleys and clamps and boots
that's supposed to keep me up.
And they're actually working.
Oh.
DILLON: Yes, beautiful.
You got it, dude.
Dude, this is awesome.
Yeah, Jeff!
JEFF: As I'm going through it,
I'm starting to get
the hang of it and I'm,
I'm understanding
the mechanisms of it.
DILLON: Keep it coming.
JEFF: I am in a zone.
DILLON: Yes, dude!
JEFF: Whoo!
I don't even feel the
aches and pains from kayaking.
DILLON: Ooh!
(yelling)
DILLON: Yeah, dude!
JEFF: Bro!
DILLON: Yeah!
JEFF: Oh my gosh!
DILLON: Right on!
JEFF: Oh...
DILLON: That was amazing.
JEFF: My gosh!
DILLON: That was incredible.
JEFF: We did that.
I was like so nervous, I
didn't think my feet would like
be able to like hold on.
But it, it works.
You know, I'm proud of how
I was able to stay calm and
just focus on the things that
will get me through this safely.
And if I can do it here, maybe I
can do it at tomorrow's fiesta.
DILLON: So what do you think?
You feel ready
for the balloon now?
JEFF: Bro, I
think I, I might be.
This took me like out of
my comfort zone for real.
DILLON: There you go.
JEFF: And bro, after that
spill doing the kayaking,
this is the
confidence boost I needed.
DILLON: Excellent.
Glad to provide, man.
JEFF: All right, man.
DILLON: Next time
you come to New Mexico,
stay on the rocks,
stay out of the water.
JEFF: Like I don't
know what else to tell you.
Let's bring on this balloon.
Whoo! Let's go!